Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris
it's a perfect game
[Laughter]
that was the most beautiful thing I'd
ever seen
[Music]
I played for five minutes
still see falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
[Music]
it's the perfect game Tetris Tetris
Tetris Tetris Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Russian
inventor he likes tennis
this game isn't just addictive it stays
with you this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity hey only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy packaging with
Tetris can you get us the rights
the show Butte Union had worldwide
rights nothing gets out easily I'm gonna
go to Moscow you're walking into a
country they're still considers America
enemy Numero Uno okey dokey you sure you
don't have to talk to your wife about
this first pioneers have to bet the
house to win but not literally listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire Mr Hodges have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
foreign
do you know where your husband is what
the hell is going on the world is
changing and Soviet Union will not be
left behind you want to play with the
big boys this is how the world Works
where is my money this is insane we
can't protect you sometimes you gotta
forget you
[Music]
this is Criminal
the Soviet Union is about to implode
they're lying everybody
recovery is coming we don't have time I
have a plan
oh come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
[Music]